this is been panner with wired I've come
to advanced driving security
incorporated to learn how to act like a
CIA or a KGB agent and test my evasive
driving skills
let's talk technique and how the day is
going to fall well first we work on some
water catering to men cross the center
line
early and snake through as you go
through technique is the red eyes but I
look at the or the license plate
of the car in front the front dog
whoever that is is the responsible for
driving the correct path of travel they
can take notes first what I want you to
do we're gonna have the rear car come
down take the outside position we're
gonna come in at the same contact for
you're just gonna drive into it this
power go around and you're gonna
continue down the road very when we're
doing ramming into the axle creating
enough force to move this mass we train
several different law enforcement
agencies government agencies and
security types of fortune 500 companies
that really protect principles so well
we're hoping to get across is two things
one that they can be safe on ferry
traffic but on the other side of the
house there is a potential that an
ambush could happen and their principal
or precious cargo or company's most
valuable assets are at risk in in one
sense on an offensive maneuver which is
vehicle take out sand and ramming
through potential has it's a deliberate
action it don't make no mistake about it
it's an actual technique to get the
principle out of harm's way we're going
home we're taking the principle with us
a we're going home today and that's a
successful security drivers job you know
the overall point of the course is
really how to how to control your own
vehicle and when you know there are
other situations you can't control
around you I think this is a perfect
example of that you know and then for a
souvenir you can take home a healthy
dose of whiplash
you